[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique
nos forêts sont de plus en plus
fréquentée par les chasseurs les
cueilleurs de champignons les sportifs
les promeneurs oui mais à qui appartient
cette forêt c'est le coeur du débat
d'aujourd'hui avec trois invités sur ce
plateau
tout d'abord daniel bouchon qui est le
président du comité de haute saône de la
fédération française de randonnée face à
lui pierre février qui est le directeur
de la fédération des chasseurs du
département du doubs et puis gilles
benest qui représente ici france nature
environnement
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez commenter
réagir à cette émission
grâce à twitter et au hashtag dit mme
paul fc comme dimanche en politique
franche comté alors on commence par un
témoignage recueilli par thierry
chauffour et de nicole un témoignage
exceptionnel donné vie ce qu a fait la
une de l'actualité il ya trois ans il
s'en serait bien passé alors qu'il fait
du vtt avec des amis en forêt à venise
près de besançon il reçoit un éclat de
balle d'un chasseur elle lui traverse
l'avant bras dans le coeur ou dans la
tête il serait mort la suite de
l'histoire est aussi édifiante
on les écoute j'ai entendu trois coups
de fusil fin de et puis le troisième il
m'a c'est un éclat de balle qui m'a
touché à l'avant bras sur le coup
chasseur est venu parce qu'il a eu la
peur de sa vie du aussi je pense
heureusement j'avais des amis vététistes
dont lé pompier c'est lui qui m'a fait
les premiers soins à le garrot en
attendant que les secours arrivent et
après plus aucune nouvelle pour les
chasseurs ça va faire trois ans que ça
s'est produit j'ai eu absolument aucune
nouvelle l'appréhension dès que j'en
tire un coup de feu ce soir à pied en
mai aux nettement je me je revois la
scène et la dernière fois que j'y suis
allé c'était l'an dernier dans la forêt
de venise on est retombé sur le groupe
de chasseurs je ne sais pas si c'est
elle et elle est même il y en a on a
pris un chemin qui n'était pas balisé
enfin contre il est pas de marquage
particulier pas de chasse en cours rien
on arrive au bout de ce chemin les
chasseurs nous ont menacés nous ont dit
que si on allait passer devant eux au
risque et de se prendre une balle et il
y en a même un qui m'a reconnu et qui
m'a dit m'a dit oh toi mon gars c'est à
passerelle de son
[Musique]
alors tout de suite pierre février en
tant que directeur de la fédération des
chasseurs du doubs je me tourne vers
vous vous en pensez quoi de ce genre
d'attitude
je suis affligé ya pas des n'y a pas
d'autre mot c'est absolument infligeant
de tenir ce genre de propos a d'avoir ce
genre d'attitude ça c'est ça c'est clair
ce que je voudrais juste préciser c'est
que à l'époque de l'accident j'étais
déjà en fonction et les présidents de la
fédération à tentait de rentrer en
contact avec la personne via son
entourage et il a été répondu qu' il
fallait attendre un petit peu depuis
il n'y a pas de nouvelles je pense que
c'est de ce point de vue là plutôt un
malentendu parce que chaque fois qu'on a
un souci on prend contact avec la
personne
on essaye d'échanger avec elle alors
daniel bush où vous vous êtes donc comme
je le disais représentants du comité
pour la haute saône de france de la
fédération française de randonnée est ce
que vous vous avez déjà eu peur en forêt
en haute saône non non mais on a une
pratique tout à fait simple on prévient
les les communes et les chasseurs ont
alors téléphone quinze jours avant il
nous précise leur plan de chasse et
c'est vous qui vous adapter et on
s'adapte ou s'adapte à ça peut aller
dans les deux sens que ça va dans les
deux sens et c'est même très souvent les
chasseurs qui les placent leur chasse
pour eau pour nous mais vous vous êtes
formelle à titre personnel vous n'avez
jamais eu peur en haute saône
jamais je me tourne vers vous qui
représentez france nature environnement
gilles benest vous avez déjà eu peur des
chasseurs comme j'étais gamin on se
promener en forêt en criant ça résolvait
beaucoup de problèmes et maintenant vous
priez plus comme vous promener en forêt
j'essaye d'écouter les chants d'oiseaux
des choses comme ça
on essaye d'éviter les moments où il ya
des coups de fusil ou même des moteurs
parce que y'a pas que les chasseurs qui
dérange dans la forêt une question
pierre février quand on se promène en
forêt et qu'on a affaire à des chasseurs
agressif en tant que citoyen lambda on a
quoi comme j'allais dire solution mais à
part peut-être de faire demi tour parce
que ils sont armés et nous pas oui
possible
je pense que ya pas de vrai quand on a
affaire à quelqu'un d'agressif qu'ils
soient chasseurs soir mais ou pas il
faut mieux tourner les talons partir il
vaut mieux tourner les talons on va on
va pas chercher là mais après ça il faut
s'adresser au maire de la commune au
président de la société de chasse on
peut faire des choses comme ça
les deux et puis à la fédération nous
appeler
quand il ya un souci on tentera de
résoudre et il faut savoir aussi que ce
type d'attitude peut être sanctionné
donc le cas échéant une personne peut se
voir retirer son droit de chasser parce
qu'elle a ce genre d'attitude
inacceptable justement on va parler
maintenant de la sécurité on va donc
c'est un exemple malheureuse qui ce qui
s'est passé il ya trois ans dans la
forêt de venise pour la saison 2017-2018
en france on a décompté 113 accident de
chasse dont 13 mortels sont des chiffres
qui proviennent de l'office national de
la chasse mais là la sécurité jeu c'est
une préoccupation pour vous à la
fédération du doubs vous avez mam était
la première fédération de france a
instauré une formation obligatoire parce
que vous étiez conscient qu'il fallait
pas confié un fusil à n'importe qui bien
sûr pour nous c'est un souci majeur est
quotidien un accident c'est un accident
de trop donc face à ça il y a un certain
nombre d'outils qu'il faut développer
on va en parler on est là pour le faire
qu'il faut développer pour tenter de 2
qu'il n'y en ait plus un seul et vous
former à peu près un millier de
chasseurs par an dans le département
voilà la 2 en 2011 on a décidé que
chaque chasseur du département devait
avoir suivi une formation sanctionnée
par une attestation à la sécurité à la
chasse on va voir justement le nombre
d'accidents de chasse depuis 2003 en 15
ans en franche comté
il y a eu au total 69 accident et il y a
eu quand même sept décès donc dus à des
accidents de chasse en franche comté au
cours de ces 15 dernières années mais
vous faites quoi
c'est à dire qu'au cours de cette
formation si vous rendez compte que
quelqu'un n'est pas capable de tenir un
fusil vous vous lui accordez pas la
formation alors
on n'en a pas le droit actuellement le
code de l'environnement précise que les
dispositions qui doivent être prises en
cas de la capacité doivent être prises
par le préfet ou le juge
donc ce n'est pas dans les compétences
de la fédération et vous pouvez signaler
nous on peut et on le fait daniel
bouchaud est ce que vous êtes rassurés
quand vous entendez que bon il ya quand
même des efforts qui sont faits auprès
des chasseurs pour la sécurité oui nous
on est rassuré parce qu'on n'a jamais
déploré une seule occident au cours de
deux loups ont donné mais vous avez
quand même vous des consignes de
sécurité vous disiez tout à l'heure que
vous organisez avec les chefs pour
savoir où ils chassent et vous organisé
entre vous mais en même temps vous avez
des consignes de sécurité très strictes
que vous faites appliquer à vos groupes
bien sûr le port du gilet maintenant que
pratiquement obligatoire c'est pas agir
et jonas et agile et je fluo f1 fluo là
de façon à ce qu' ils soient bien
visibles par les chaînes tout à fait y
en a en général un en tête ont par
l'animateur et un par le service qui est
à l'arrière et qui veille à ce que tout
le monde soit rassemblé surtout
lorsqu'on passe dans les zones de chasse
de tout le monde rassemblé serre qu'il
faut marcher en groupe bien phû en
chantant un peu comme faisait monsieur
banier d'activité gêne pas tellement
le show et tout le monde respecte les
tout à fait mais c'est quand même aussi
un paradoxe parce que quand on veut
aller se balader dans la forêt ce dès
fois pour être celle où soit forcément
avoir une structure avec des consignes
de sécurité strictes oui mais enfin en
général c'est quand même très court le
sentier pas sans limites et c'est donc
ce n'est pas pendant toute la randonnée
a donc pour eux on fait attention
pendant cette zone
gilles benest vous en pensez quoi vous
je pense que il y a des moments je le
disais d'ailleurs à pierre février dans
une réunion récente il faudrait qu'on
prenne exemple sur les chasseurs vous
l'avez bien vu sur les photos sur tous
les reportages les chasseurs ont tous un
gilet fluorescent pour être visible de
loin pour être sûr qu'entre déjà ils se
mélangent pas et c'est ce que vous venez
de dire il faudrait qu'on se promène en
forêt avec ses gilets pour ba ne pas
être confondu avec un gibier moi ce à un
moment donné ça me chiffonne un petit
peu quand même
la nature est ce qu'elle est c'est quand
même un lieu de liberté c'est un lieu de
détente c'est un lieu où on doit
profiter où on peut profiter des
senteurs des bruits de cette
particularité qui n'est pas le milieu
urbain s'il faut y aller
protégé par une armure leur pardon
monsieur février sur cette comparaison
un peu abusive un gilet n'est pas une
armure mais quand même s'il faut
s'habiller pour y aller je trouve c'est
quand même un empiètement sur notre
hôtel on va faire empiètement sur la
liberté individuelle
monsieur février là là là où je vous
rejoins bien volontiers je pense que
c'est surtout à nous de faire attention
aux autres
par rapport à notre pratique donc imposé
un vêtement en particulier ou un signe
je pense que ce n'est pas à nous de le
faire
par contre pour nous mêmes on l'a fait
c'est notre choix et ça ne doit pas
faire diminuer la vigilance de chacun
d'entre nous donc je crois que le juste
la juste position elle est peut-être un
peu entre les deux si si ça rassure
quelqu'un de le mettre
qu'il le fasse avec grand plaisir c'est
pas nous le prouve justement a priori de
l'ap la sécurité n'est pas toujours
assurée de votre côté donc il y a quand
même des associations qui demandent
qu'un jour par semaine il n'y ait pas de
chasse sur notre territoire notamment
par exemple le dimanche puisque c'est là
où il ya le plus de monde dans les bois
vous en tant que directeur de la
fédération des chasseurs du doubs vous
en dites quoi
vous envisagez de ne pas chasser un jour
et peut-être même le dimanche et alors
vous l'avez dire en tant que directeur
j'ai une vision qui est légèrement
différente
vous allez être courte non mais je vais
dire que c'est pas tout à fait aussi
simple que il y a des moments il y a des
périodes dans l'année et il y à des
lieux où les choses s'y prêtent plus ou
moins et le faire fixer un jour comme
sarbe arbitrairement
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué qui peut
qu'elle peut y paraître
ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya des
chasseurs qui me fait ch à ce que le
dimanche par exemple la majorité d'entre
eux sont des actifs sains c'est quand
même un peu de retraités cas il ya des
retraités la moyenne d'âge dans gangs
dans le doubs elle est de 52 ans
des chasseurs donc ça veut dire que la
majorité d'entre eux et est active
ensuite
c'est pas la même chose quand on est en
décembre en janvier ou en février
le dimanche après midi dans les bois que
le mois de septembre octobre il fait
froid donc et les gens devraient rester
chez eux parce qu'ils doivent rester ce
qu'ils sortent un peu moins comment on
va demander son avis donc à monsieur
bouchaud vous ça vous rassure rêve vous
êtes pour un jour sans chasse par
semaine bien sûr bien sûr il y aura
certainement plus de randonnées
organisées ce jour-là sa d'ignobles oui
vous êtes plutôt pour oui bien sûr je
veux c'est ben est alors de voler
d'abord je pense que si les chasseurs
tous
il ya toujours des exceptions mais
parlons des bons chasseurs acceptait un
jour non chassés dans la semaine ce
serait un signal très fort pour la
société vous dit un jour par sedan la
semaine et même par exemple mercredi ça
vous paraîtra bien on n'entre pas dans
ce détail là pour l'instant parce
qu'effectivement si on fait ça un mardi
ou un vendredi sa pas le même sens il
faut quand même prendre et monsieur
février bien dit le jour de la semaine
où il ya beaucoup de gens qui doivent se
partager l'espace justement donc si les
chasseurs faisait ce geste là ce serait
vis-à-vis de la société un geste
extrêmement important je sais pas si
l'on pensait jusqu'à présent
mais quand même pas oublier une chose
c'est que les chasseurs le son de très
loin pas la majorité dans la société
alors qu'on a on va entendre votre
premier volet ont fait réagir monsieur
février vous n'êtes pas la majorité il y
a dans le doubs huit mille chasseurs en
france 1 million
les chiffres qu'on m'a donnée c'est
c'est à peu près 15 millions de
personnes qui pratiquent la randonnée la
marche apx état dans la forêt donc vous
êtes numériquement en infériorité
pourriez faire un petit j'ai besoin
c'est évident enfin je voudrais juste
après apporter de précisions le le
chiffre officiel est que
personnellement je trouve adapté parce
que les statistiques moi je des mages
les manies à chaque journée c'est un
million cent mille chasseurs
ensuite le bien entendu il ya beaucoup
plus d'autres d'autres utilisateurs
ce qu'il faut préciser aussi c'est que
ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas en
franche comté la franche comté à une
situation un peu particulière par
rapport par rapport à ça mais ce qu'on
n'a pas cité c'est que chacun des
terrains concernés et forestiers ou
agricoles ou propriétaires et que dans
d'autres régions
ce n'est pas le cas dans le dos
puisqu'il ya une réglementation peu
particulière dans d'autres régions il
ce propriétaire a donné ou c'est
lui-même qui exerce son droit de chasse
sur ses sur ces terrains des promeneurs
qui vont sur des terrains qui leur
appartiennent pas assez ça que vous
voulez dire donc le propriétaire fait ce
qu'il veut ah bah c'est pas qui fait ce
qu'il veut c'est qu'il a il il est qu'il
reste quand même le propriétaire des
terrains il ya deux choses
les propriétaires privés ont beaucoup de
difficulté à ne pas refaire pas pouvoir
refuser le nouvel âge légal très précis
on va pas rentrer là dedans parce que
c'est pas l'heure de jeu il dirait que
là c'est quand même un point important
pour les autres pour le citoyen
ordinaire et pour le chasseur quand il
n'a pas de fusil parce qu'il ya d'autres
moments où ils les promeneurs comme nous
tous
là il ya un droit d'aller à venir
d'aller et venir une liberté
constitutionnelle à la circulation qui
est extrêmement importante et qui vaut
pour tout le monde
par exemple cueilleurs de champignons il
ya une sorte d' usage où il a le droit
d'aller se promener
même en dehors des chemins temps qu'eux
et ça c'est une règle extrêmement
importante qui avait été discutée
notamment au moment où on a mis natura
2000 en place en france on peut aller
dans les parcelles sous réserve de ne
pas y faire d'idée cette pression de
traces particulières
donc y'a pas de souci particulier pour
le promeneur pour quelqu'un qui se
promènent à pied
éventuellement même pour quelqu'un qui
se promène à vélo quand ils restent sur
les chemins quand on est avec un moteur
c'est un autre problème
les dégâts sur les chemins sont en sont
d'une autre nature
allez dans une parcelle n'importe qui
peut y aller qu'on soit dans une
propriété publique ou privée après
évidemment faut faire attention si c'est
une parcelle en régénération ou pas mais
ce qui se passe déjà ce que j'ai appris
en faisant cette émission c'est qu'en
forêt de chailluz donc à besançon il ya
des chasse en forêt de chailluz elles
sont déjà interdite le dimanche
après-midi au public
preuve que c'est faisable c'est possible
ah ben
si le propriétaire qui est là qui est la
commune en forêt de chailluz lalalala
décidé bien entendu mais encore une fois
j'ai appris parce qu'il y avait six
jours et demi de chasse à châlus savais
que je ne savais pas forcément peuvent
potentiellement potentiels votants
potentiels possible potentiel après
encore une fois et là c'est bien la
démonstration que le propriétaire a
décidé du de l'utilisation de l'espace
dont il a joui des tilal la propriété la
pleine propriété
le ramassage des champignons par exemple
est un usage un certain nombre de
propriétaires en interdisent la
possibilité dans un certain nombre de
départements
pourquoi voir que même voir des mères
aussi sur certaines heures il est maire
donc là là là il faut pas si simple non
plus non plus que ça ceci ne va pas tout
résoudre en une demi heure d'émission on
est bien d'accord
soyons unis non soyons en sûrs mais un
longeron simple par vous là mais après
la question qui se pose c'est quand même
comment aux 100 ans les uns et les
autres pour profiter les uns et les
autres de la forêt comment vous vous
organisez vous avec les chasseurs de
haute saône où nous avait dit tout à
l'heure que vous vous téléphoner mais
vous utilisez même les cabane de chasse
voilà où l'eau ça nous est souvent
arrivé pour pique par exemple
lorsque le temps est incertain de poser
la question et volontiers une muse
ouvrent leur cabane de chasse pour qu'on
puisse se restaurer et vous pensez que
ça c'est un modèle qui peut être
appliqué à d'autres départements ou
parce que c'est eux et parce que c'est
vous en nous je pense que ça doit
s'impliquer partout notre espace il est
ce qu'il est il faut que tout le monde
ne partage
il est pas y'a pas un espace pour les
randonneurs un espace pour les
cueilleurs de champignons pour les
chasseurs etc vous ce que vous trouvez
cette lobby des chasseurs pèse un peu
trop lourd en france 1 si vous voulez le
problème moi qui utilise des mots le
bien vous n'avez pas utilisé non et j'ai
pas envie de l'utiliser
parce qu' il serait parfaitement
réciproque télé chasseurs nous dirait à
raison d'ailleurs que nous-mêmes avait
fait ne nous sommes à l'aube et je crois
qu'on peut jouer au ping-pong comme ça
ça pas beaucoup ça progresse pas ce que
je constate quand même je reviens aux
propos je tenais tout à l'heure c'est
que notre territoire pour une part est
un bien commun au sens où soit il
appartient à personne puisque le gibier
res nullius si j'ai bien compris
soit il est effectivement classé bien de
la collectivité exemple la forêt de
chailluz ce que je constate c'est que il
y a des moments quand même relativement
important où il ya une appropriation
pour une toute petite partie de la
société pardon pour le tout petit
parce que c'est pas un million cent ça
c'est les chiffres officiels mais en
réalité on est quand même bien en
dessous du million on est plutôt aux
alentours de 800 850 mille chasseurs en
france moi aussi j'ai les statistiques
ils sont à peu près le même nombre que
nous en terme de militants actifs etc
sauf que nous on a intérêt d'intérêt
général il y à une appropriation à
travers l'activité de chasse de deux
choses d'une part l'objet lui même quel
animal qui es-tu et qu'il est ni dans
l'assiette que j'ai souvent proposés aux
chasseurs d'ailleurs de partager avec
eux mais ils m'ont pas encore invité
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya déjà
c'est pas un végétarien visiblement le
nan mais chez qui ce sont des bons
vivants aussi donc bon la deuxième
chance qu'ils s'approprient et qui est
aussi un bien collectif c'est l'espace
l'espace n'importe quel citoyen sous
réserve bien évidemment du respect
d'autrui et c est a partagé par tout le
monde et il ya des moments où on n'y
arrive pas alors je veux bien qu'on dise
que ce qui se passe en haute saône est
exemplaire et que ça puisse se faire
ailleurs
moi j'ai jamais je vous le disais on
prépare et se préparant cette émission
je n'ai personnellement jamais rencontré
un chasseur qui soit un viandard et j'ai
eu beaucoup de chance de ce point de vue
là mais en attendant on constate quand
même qui a pas mal de problèmes un petit
peu partout alors je me refuse c'est
pour ça que je veux pas utiliser le mot
lobby à jeter l'opprobre sur toute une
catégorie de la société fussent ils des
chasseurs des agriculteurs août
mais quand même on va enfin avant ses
problèmes
on va avancer un petit peu justement sur
cette question de comment s'entendre
comment s'organiser les uns et les
autres puisque j'ai reçu des questions
de téléspectateurs par exemple de gilles
qui pratiquent le trail
il a déjà eu des petites frictions avec
les chasseurs et voudrait bien cohabiter
avec eux mais il regrette justement
qu'on ne trouve nulle part des
informations sur les dates et des lieux
de chasse et j'ai eu la même question de
marques qui lui et vététistes est-ce que
c'est faisable sa de maître vous à la
fédération sur votre site
eh bien tu es le jour il ya une chasse à
tel endroit à telle autre sur tel
périmètre alors il ya un certain nombre
de dispositifs qui existent déjà dans un
certain nombre de communes certaines par
exemple affiche les lieux de chasse un
endroit convenu dans la commune est
connue d'à peu près tout le monde se
soit très souvent mairie en mairie ou
sur le tableau d'affichage à l'heure
d'internet et des téléphones portables
et tout ça on y vient un certain nombre
de deux décès sont en cours pour que
soit sur des applications smartphone
soit sur des sites internet la l'accès à
l'information soit possible pour tout le
monde donc c'est est là sont en cours
ils vont vraisemblablement se développer
il ya par exemple des essais en haute
savoie vous de savoir qui fait l'objet
de vététistes qui a été tuée par un
chasseur vététistes anglais d'une
trentaine d'années tué par un chasseur
au mois d'octobre et donc il ya aussi en
alsace quelques tentatives un grand
terrain de chasse bien entendu et grand
terrain de randonnée il ya une tradition
de cohabitation permanente je je je
reviens sur ce sur sur ce point là en
alsace il n'y a pas plus d'accidents
qu'ailleurs il n'y a pas de non chasse
le dimanche en alsace crois que
l'histoire du la question du jour est un
faux problème parce que là le le cas de
chailluz par exemple en septembre n'est
pas le même que une commune extrêmement
rural mois de février ou même au mois
deux mois de septembre et que chaque
lieu doivent eux faire l'objet de deux
doses choix commun qui va être fait qui
devrait être fait avec les randonneurs
avec les utilisateurs de la nature jeu
ils sont invités à participer à ce type
de choix ce type de décision dans chaque
fédération tous les six ans parce que
tous les six ans et vous l'avez fait
récemment je crois te fait au printemps
on rédige et en gros là la dynamique
politique pour les pour les six ans à
venir les espèces de charte
c'est raconter monsieur bush où nous
avons une réunion où nous étions conviés
avec fédération de chasse des chasseurs
pardon c'était la fédération des
chasseurs qui a invité tous leurs
invités pour vous proposer un peu ce
plan de protection des gibiers etc etc
donc vous êtes quelque part associés
officiellement tout le feu et vous
seriez d'accord pour qu'ils y est sur un
site internet des lieux de chasse des
applications sur les téléphones
portables
oui je pense que c'est l'avenir toute
façon il va falloir y aller oui c'est
difficile de passer à côté
autant utiliser les moyens dont on
dispose
si on vous donne à choisir entre le site
internet elle dimanche sans chasse ou
choisissez quoi quoi je choisirais pas
me le mariage des deux me paraît une
bonne solution
monsieur benest sur justement les
nouvelles technologies est ce que vous
pensez que c'est une bonne idée et c'est
vers ça qu'il faut aller je je dis
maintenant parce qu'il reste pas
beaucoup de points je veux pas qu'il
faille rouge vif ou par non je dis pas
il faut aller jeudi on peut aller il ya
probablement d'autres moyens et je
partage tout à fait cette rencontre là
y'a juste quand même une chose c'est que
ce genre de rencontre se fait avec les
citoyens qui sont organisées dans des
associations
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les
activités de loisirs en pleine nature et
on s'aperçoit que le gros problème mais
ça vaut tout particulièrement pour la
randonnée pédestre canton compte vos
adhérents à 230 milles au niveau
national et 5 millions de randonneurs
actifs
voilà un oeuf et ça ça montre bien qu
réalité quand vous touchez la fédération
vous touchez pas tout le monde
l comment on fait avec les autres alors
ça le 1er février une réponse et on
touche là la question de la
représentation dans dans le cas vous
vous êtes super bien organisé et voulait
r oui mais les randonneurs aussi et
citoyen ordinaire c'est ça le problème
et monsieur madame tout le monde je suis
désolé mais on laisse parler monsieur
février mais vous pensez vous que vous
avez des efforts à faire et que vous
êtes dans le bon sens vous aller dans le
bon sens en tout cas en tout cas on y
travaille et en tout cas on a fait
l'effort mais pas seulement les forces
je crois que c'est avec grand plaisir la
fédération du doubs elle fait son
assemblée générale à la fédération des
chasseurs
voilà on sait ce sera le mot de la fin
donc visiblement cet espace à partager
eh bien on y va tout doucement mais
sûrement merci de votre attention ou
dimanche après midi à tous au revoir
on
[Musique]